all right we have this from truth social
Donald Trump has posted saying the
corrupt Biden Administration has
informed my attorneys that I have been
indicted seemingly over the Box's hoax
even though Joe Biden has 1850 boxes at
the University of Delaware additional
boxes in Chinatown DC with even more
boxes at the University of Pennsylvania
and documents thrown all over his garage
floor where he Parks his Corvette and
which is quote secured by only a garage
door that is paper thin and open much of
the time he continues I have been
summoned to appear at the federal
courthouse in Miami on Tuesday at 3 pm I
never thought it would I never thought
it possible that such a thing could
happen to a former president of the
United States who received far more
votes than any sitting president in the
history of our country and is currently
leading by far all candidates both
Democrat and Republican in polls of the
2024 presidential election I am an
innocent man
this is indeed a dark day for the United
States of America we are a country in
serious and Rapid decline but together
we will make America great again
Elon Musk has chimed in responding to
Alx posting this saying there does seem
to be far higher interest in pursuing
Trump compared to other people in
politics very important the justice
justice system rebut what appears to be
differential enforcement or they will
lose public trust Elon I appreciate the
sentiment but you are a couple years too
late it's happening the Federal
indictment by the Biden doj is direct
election interference it is subversion
of the United States election it's just
I don't even know what to say other than
yo look man I don't see how this country
remains on this path I don't see how the
United States stands and continues to
function when you've got the sitting
president filing an indictment against
his chief rival
and the same day and we'll get to in a
minute where evidence is coming out
proving Biden is corrupt and was brought
and was taking bribes well not just
Biden right the entire political
establishment has been for a very long
time and we've seen selective
prosecutions occur I think in the case
of Dinesh D'Souza it was very obvious
that his prosecution was politically
motivated though he did commit a crime
it's one that typically uh is not
pursued in one which almost never
carries the penalty which he received
which was jail time so this has been
happening for a while here and now
they're just moving on to higher and
higher profile people like the former
president of the United States and one
of the number one polling people who's
currently running in 2024. When Donald
Trump said that he if he was in charge
of the justice system in the United
States Hillary Clinton would be in jail
and an absolutely brilliant moment which
was hilarious and very rhetorically
effective the response from the media
was this sets a very dangerous precedent
now I think it's a little bit different
right because there are things that
Hillary Clinton has done that we can
point to and say
almost anyone else who had done these
things would at the very least be
investigated and very likely be
prosecuted now with Donald Trump what
they're trying to nail him for is having
classified documents even though he as
president had the authority to
declassify them and did so so there's
absolutely nothing here but they want to
lock him up because he is setting an
example for the American people and so
now they need to make one out of him I
shared I sure think that Trump uh I bet
Trump regrets not Prosecuting Hillary
Clinton I was like we're gonna lock her
up and then as soon as he got elected
like we're not gonna do it and now he's
probably really upset that he didn't
because they're coming after him with
with everything they've got well he had
a weak uh uh justice department from the
beginning remember sessions gave in
right away it must have been a month
into the administration yep they went
after Flynn he VP fired Flynn and we sat
through four four years of this Russia
hoax every day CNN MSNBC the whole
mainstream Rush hoax and there was
nothing there but Jeff session appointed
a special prosecutor right off the bat
and we have to live with that you think
do you think America no point a special
prosecutor look into Joe Biden's five
billion never we have two two uh tears
of Justice in this country I thought it
was interesting that they released this
uh on a Thursday at 7 40 p.m right
before we go live like I'm not saying
we're the center of the universe but do
they want to make a public spectacle is
this more about Trump announced it
that's true that's true I was watching
podcast and I thought quite frankly they
should break it I would love that
um let's see if we can get them on the
phone if they want to be amazing if they
if they want to make a public spectacle
is it is the goal here to humiliate
Donald Trump or is the goal to put him
in jail both yeah I think context here
is very important so Donald Trump will
be the first former president who's ever
been indicted on something this is the
second time he's going to be indicted so
first in New York City the Manhattan
district attorney was working with the
grand jury to indict Trump for the
so-called hush money payments to stormy
Daniel now we have the Department of
Justice I'm looking to these classified
documents the second indictment that's
ever come up also there's I think
potentially a third indictment that's
going to come from Georgia
um surrounding efforts to potentially
with what he said with um looking for
votes uh with that whole Scandal there's
also another civil suit against the
Trump organization about lying to
lenders and insurers about his assets
but what's key here is that this is the
first former president to and be
indicted and I know there's a myth that
nobody's above the law but guess what
the president and former presidents
actually are above the law there's a lot
of things that people could have thought
of to indict former presidents on we
spoke about it earlier Barack Obama Drew
and American citizens overseed whether
or not that you some people think that's
Justified that's something that could
potentially be indicted on people call
George Bush that say that he started an
illegal war in Iraq but no the first
indictment of a former president that
we're seeing is initially for hush money
payments and now this Declassified
documentation you're going to start
making me support this I mean if this
opens the door for us to go after former
president and prosecute them man I hope
he gets off and he should but let's do
it well what they say if this is the
first former president no exactly agreed
I agree if they indicted Trump over the
Commando raids in Yemen that resulted in
the death of allegedly the death of an
American Girl abdur manalaki's sister
that one is more conjecture than
abdulrahman al-alaki but should be
investigated if they indicted him for
that said an investigation found this to
be the case I'd be like well what do you
want me to say you you ordered these
raids and you kill American citizens you
get charged they're not doing that
they're not because we won't do that
because then everyone's gonna be like Mr
Obama right this way sir into this
vehicle you know what though they're so
Shameless that they would prosecute
Trump for something like that and just
not look into Obama or Biden I mean
that's the whole point people are all
criminals and then all the people on
Twitter would be like well look salute
Justified because in this instance yeah
it's also dangerous though because when
a Republican president will eventually
get back into office we will see
attorney generals in different states
say hey let's go indict a former
Democrat let's go investigate until we
find something a good prosecutor it
could indict a rock so right we don't
know what the indictment is right now
it's definitely a process crime which is
kind of a joke and years ago they got
Martha Stewart on a processed crime so
when you bring enough of his staff in
front of the grand jury and somebody
forgets one little thing because they
can't have the exact memory oh the
alliance so it's very easy when you have
the whole weight of the justice
department behind you millions of
dollars they can get you on anything
this is a real joke they're not going to
get him that he's holding documents
because he's ex-president then you'd
have to go get Biden you'd have to go
get Pence you'd have to go get Obama so
it's just going to be a silly process
crime but they want to stop Trump from
running and they want to stop him from
do you guys want to see when a
republican is eventually president again
that um attorney generals from Red
States go after former Democrat
absolutely and former reporters
that's not how it would be though it'd
be hyper depends on the Republican but
you're probably right if most
Republicans wouldn't but I think
somebody like Trump would maybe yeah
yeah I think part of what makes this
country green and has made it great is
that we haven't fallen into Petty
squabble like that in not 250 years like
we just don't do that because we have
bigger dishes short short your time span
here buddy okay
860. yeah I mean it's been since the
Civil War you could say right okay but
for the most part Petty squabble that
was that wasn't Petty yeah that was a
big deal we had to end slavery and you
know there was it was a big problem but
this is like just he said she said he's
carrying a box of documents he's he he
signed this paperwork he ordered that
kill he ordered that kill like yo it's
the biggest military in the world it's
the most dangerous machine on Earth and
someone's got to point the buttons point
the point the guns
um I I just there's so many more bigger
problems on Earth that we should be
focused on than than arresting past
political opponents it's so ridiculous
man
is what's going to happen well this is
what's really shocking I I shouldn't say
shocking but something worth pointing
out and it's that there are two segments
of the population and they're relatively
large demographics okay these are people
who are either in category a willfully
ignorant or in category B not willfully
ignorant who believe that this is the
first time since Nixon that an American
president has done something worthy of
pursuing with an indictment or charges
there are people are looking at this and
they're saying oh my goodness all of our
presidents have behaved within the law
and haven't committed war crimes haven't
betrayed the American people haven't
portrayed their oath of office and then
Donald Trump came along and there are
good reasons to indict that man and the
best of them is that he had Declassified
documents that he Declassified himself
people are willing to believe this well
the remarkable thing is the logic makes
no sense if Trump can't declassify
anything at any time then he's literally
not the authority of this country to
have conversations pertaining to war how
can you be the commander-in-chief of the
Armed Forces and then this is the
example I gave last time it's like you
meet with Vladimir Putin and he's like
you know I want you to move these
missiles out of this territory what
missiles yeah okay we know the U.S has
missiles here you move them otherwise
it's War I'm sorry I can't confirm our
deny I don't have the authority Biden
probably does say what missiles though
to be fair it's like what are you
talking about man I don't know what you
mean
he's like are there missiles in Ukraine
there are is oh man you think the
implication and then he gets offline
he's like I don't know if there's
missiles there I think that the
implication is that Donald Trump didn't
declassify the documents before there's
no process for it okay the president has
plenary declassification powers he can
literally just be like these are no
longer classified so I I had him on me
therefore they're not classified anymore
he did say they were Declassified
but they're like arguing there's some
kind of formal process by which the
president does not needs to get approval
from someone else but they're not going
after him on this apparently
the report is that they're charging him
with losing possession of classified
documents or something like that or of
of sensitive National Security documents
so they're actually trying to avoid the
question of whether or not he classified
or Declassified by saying it's a totally
different law now losing acts losing
control of secured documents is
something Hillary Clinton did when she
would forward all that stuff to Jake
Sullivan like out of her thirty thousand
emails or whatever she had there's there
I you know I should have one that I
could pull up right now that was
legitimate National Security risk but
she was as far as I understand not
supposed to be forwarding you know
Secretary of State documents to this guy
Jake Sullivan well Ian I think there's a
good argument to be made that every
single one of the 30 000 emails that
Hillary Clinton deleted was a potential
National Security risk if she were to be
elected for one very simple reason she
didn't want people to see those emails
and there was a receiver which means
there were people who would have the
leverage over the sitting president of
the United States of being able to
release these emails that she deleted
when she was subpoenaed so that in and
of itself means that someone else could
end up pulling the strings or someone
else could end up uh being in a position
where the president owes them this favor
because they have blackmail you mean
because someone else received documents
from Hillary anyone could have them well
no my point is so Hillary Clinton has
these 30 000 emails and then she deletes
all of them because she clearly doesn't
want an investigation to be looking into
those emails she doesn't want the
American people to see them well here's
the thing she can only delete those
emails on her end thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time